c'est-à-dire qu'il y a eu un travail de
fond quand même de manipulation pour
faire croire à cette opinion publique
que le danger en réalité venez d'Irak et
qu'il fallait donc punir ce régime
bonsoir Mamette Sifaoui vous êtes
journaliste en presse écrite en
télévision vous avez aussi publié des
livres la France malade de l'islamisme
mes frères assassins comment j'ai
infiltré une cellule d'Al-Qaïda et
aujourd'hui toujours aux éditions du
Cherche-Midi sont les traces de Ben
Laden le jeu trouble des Américains la
question est simple c'est où est donc
passé où ça m'a Ben Laden
alors d'abord on nous a dit que Ben
Laden se cachait dans ces fameuses
grottes de Tora-Bora alors à la
télévision sur LCI on voyait des coupes
comme ça de la montagne avec à
l'intérieur tout était creux il y avait
des escaliers des ascenseurs enfin
c'était super
naudant on les voyait sur LCI mais
c'était pas des images de LCI c'était
les images préparées par des
propagandistes de du Pentagone que les
les télés les télés françaises en
naïvement vous souvenez des espèces de
bunker comme ça ultra sophistiqué avec
des armatures qui empêchaient les bombes
de les bombes de pénétrer
on est allé là-bas je dis
je suis allé avec un collègue et ce
qu'on a vu sur place n'a absolument rien
à voir mais absolument rien à voir
d'ailleurs j'ai dans le livre j'ai mis
quelques photos pour pour illustrer un
petit peu ce qu'on a vu ce sont des des
grottes tout à fait
tout à fait simple et parfois outre ou
creusé par la main de l'homme ou naturel
mais tu n'avais absolument rien
d'extraordinaire en tout cas c'était
très loin de ce que les Américains nous
décrivaient ces espèces de bunker avec
enterré une couche de béton et que seuls
des des missiles spécialement conçus
pour faire pouvait perforer c'était tout
à fait loin de tout ça donc première
chose il était pas là-dedans enfin en
tous les cas c'était pas capable de le
protéger ensuite il y a toujours pour le
capturer il y a eu la fameuse opération
anaconda qui est devenu ensuite
l'opération Condor et vous dit dans
votre bouquin qu'on a surtout tué des
civils en fait oui il y a eu il y a eu
des dérapages des dérives assez graves
de la part de l'armée américaine en
Afghanistan et et donc ce que j'ai pu
dire
constater sur place et j'ai pas été le
seul c'est qu'il y a eu il y a
aujourd'hui un rejet total de la base
afghane par rapport à tout tout ce qui
tout ce que les Américains nous
racontent démocratie tout ça pour eux ce
sont des mots qui ne veulent absolument
rien dire pour eux la démocratie de la
vivre ils ont une certaine forme de
démocratie c'est ce qu'ils appellent la
luya jerga c'est-à-dire une réunion
entre de tribu qui d'une manière ou
d'une autre autour d'un débat autour
d'une tasse de thé
décide de l'avenir de telle ou de tel
autre tribu alors la thèse principale de
votre bouquin Mohamed chifaoui ils sont
finis par se demander dites-vous si les
Américains ne font pas exprès de ne pas
attraper Ben Laden et garde pas son
arrestation pour les élections
présidentielles
américaines en novembre 2004 pour vous
dire vrai et je crois qu'on a eu déjà
l'occasion d'en parler ici je suis pas
un partisan de la thèse du complot il
faut il faut le préciser j'ai bien
délimité la les responsabilités des
islamistes et depuis déjà plusieurs
années néanmoins il y a des choses qui
me posent à me poser un certain nombre
de questions et je prendrai deux cas en
particulier la première l'arrestation de
Ramzi Bena chaiba celui qui devait être
le 20e pirate de l'air durant septembre
qui a été arrêté curieusement le 11
septembre 2002 c'est-à-dire une année
jour pour jour après les attentats de
New York et de Washington vous savez je
ne soit pas vraiment qu’il existe de
hasard et de coïncidence en politique et
enjoyaux stratégie deuxième fait c'est
l'arrestation de Khaled cheikh Mohamed
celui considéré comme le numéro 3 del
Kaïda il a été arrêté le premier mars
2003 à quelques jours d'un vote qui
devait disons une résolution de la
guerre en Irak et trois semaines avant
le début des hostilités en Irak c'est
c'était aussi un moment où
George Bush avait besoin du soutien de
son opinion
ces deux personnes ont été arrêtées à
des moments stratégiques donc ce que
vous supposez d'une certaine façon c'est
que les Américains savaient où ils
étaient ils avaient logés comme on dit
dans la police et en fait ils ont
attendu la date
utile
pour moi en ce qui concerne ces deux ces
deux cas que sont celui de Ramzi
l'arrestation celle donc de Ramzy
benchaiba et et de Khaled cheikh Mohamed
ils ont ils ont attendu le moment voulu
pour pour agir c'est ça rentre dans le
cadre de calcul politiciens extrêmement
étroit étriqué mais dangereux au niveau
des calculs donc évidemment peut penser
qu'il savoue et Ben Laden mais qui
attendront les élections américaines
pour l'arrêter et en tous les cas une
chose que vous dites dans votre bouquin
c'est que il pouvait pas l'arrêter avant
l'intervention en Irak puisque la
plupart des Américains du peuple
américain sont convaincus que les gens
qui ont fait les attentats du 11
septembre sont des Irakiens ils ont pas
compris la différence ils pensent que
c'est lié donc si on arrêtait Ben Laden
avant d'intervenir en Irak c'était
saugrenu du point de vue américain moi
je pense qu'effectivement la population
l'opinion américaine a été extrêmement
manipulée dans cette histoire et Georges
W Bush avait besoin de du soutien de
cette opinion publique et donc
l'arrestation d'Oussama Ben Laden aurait
disons suscité dans le dans l'esprit le
subconscient collectif la victoire sur
le terrorisme et ils ont joué sur une
sorte d'amalgame autour du 11 septembre
sur Oussama Ben Laden le régime irakien
vous vous rappelez ces histoires de
la rencontre soit disant entre services
secrets irakiens Oussama Ben Laden ou
Mohamed hata le chef du commando ainsi
de suite on nous a ils nous ont raconté
pas mal d'histoires à ce sujet et c'est
pas moi qui le dis ce sont des sondages
réalisés aux États-Unis quelques jours
avant le début de la guerre en Irak un
Américain sur deux tenez-vous bien
croyez que les 19 pirates du 11
septembre
quand même de manipulation pour faire
croire à cette opinion publique que le
danger en réalité venez d'Irak et qu'il
fallait donc punir ce régime qui qui
aime régime dictatorial forcément on le
sait système américain même dans
l'éducation c'est comme ça il y a pas
que dans les médias c'est nous apprend
que les Américains sont les sauveurs du
monde et ils sont étonnés que quand il y
a des problèmes il y a des gens qui se
retournent contre eux ils pensent qu'ils
sauvent l'Afrique même les moi parler
avec deux trois Américains où ils sont
stupéfaits de la réaction qu'il peut y
avoir à leur rencontre ils sont pas
conscients quoi du truc alors quand on
vous dit mais il est peut-être mort Ben
Laden c'est peut-être pour ça qu'ils
n'ont pas arrêté vous dites non parce
que s'il était mort il en aurait fait un
martyr évidemment c'est à dire qu'ils
auraient montré ces funérailles
évidemment écoutez ça fait deux semaines
à peu près et à une information qui est
passée totalement inaperçue le chef de
la Légion arabe en Tchétchénie a été tué
ce sont des conditions que l'on ignore
aujourd'hui le jour de sa mort cette
information a été rendue publique par
ses propres compagnons le jour où le
commandant rattaque le prédécesseur de
ce chef de la Légion arabe en
Tchétchénie a été tué sa mort a été
filmée rendue publique et son
enterrement a été filmé rendu public
dans des sites par des sites islamistes
pourquoi pour les islamistes c'est très
important de rendre public ce genre de
de mort la mort du chef le martyre le
symbole qui va non pas affaiblir les
troupes bien au contraire parce qu'on
n'est pas dans une culture occidentale
ou il y a une stratégie faut cacher ceci
cette information parce que ça risque
d'être préjudiciable au contraire dans
leur idéologie il faut rendre un public
ce genre d'information parce que ça
galvanise les malheur le malheur est
moteur quoi absolument pour eux le
malheur est moteur d'une d'une voyée par
exemple après l'assassinat du Cher
Yassine en Palestine comment il sorte il
crie et il crie vengeance et ils
essaient de passer à l'acte ce n'est pas
du bluff les islamistes ne bluff pas et
quand ils peuvent ils tentent de passer
à la donc ben Laden pas mort Ben Laden
je ne crois pas qu'ils soi-même alors où
est-il et vous dites il est au
oasiristan voilà alors ça le loisirstan
l'Afghanistan les zones tribales entre
l'Afghanistan et le Pakistan qui sont
des zones non contrôlées disant mais
loisirs restants c'est où loisirs
restants c'est une région tribale qui se
situe entre le Pakistan et l'Afghanistan
c'est dans les zones tribales c'est une
des entrées
qui qui sont peuplés par ce qu'on
appelle les pachton donc une ethnie qui
à la fois parfois côté pakistanais
parfois côté afghan et le loisirstan est
une est une région qui est particulière
parce que c'est la région où l'idéologie
islamiste et la mieux ancrée j'allais
dire et où les gens sont très influencés
et très très proche de cette idéologie
ou ça m'a Ben Laden et considéré comme
un demi dieu et vous vous êtes allé au
loisirstant on est allé au port du oasis
Stan c'est à dire que lorsqu'on a voulu
aller comme par hasard
habituellement les intribales toutes les
intribales sont fermées aux étrangers
principalement aux journalistes quand on
a voulu aller je suis parti comme ça
faire un peu le naïf auprès d'une
autorité locale le représentants du
ministère de l'Intérieur pakistanais à
peshawa et je leur ai dit je veux aller
dans une dans les intribales ils m'ont
dit il y a pas de problème allez allez-y
et vous voulez aller où exactement j'ai
dit oasiristan ils m'ont dit non vous
pouvez aller partout sauf au loisirs
alors j'ai dit pourquoi
le responsable qui m'a répondu m'a dit
non parce qu'il y a un conflit entre
deux tribus ça serait dangereux pour
vous je dis bon écoutez je vous signe ce
que vous voulez une décharge je prends
mes responsabilités je suis un adulte je
suis journaliste je veux y aller et en
fait j'ai insisté il voulait absolument
rien savoir et à ce moment-là je l'ai un
peu provoqué j'ai dit pourquoi il y a ou
ça m'a baladin qui se cache là-bas et là
il m'a foutu dehors donc bon c'est un
indice parmi d'autres mais disons que
j'ai une certaine rigueur qui me permet
pas de tirer des conclusions à la suite
de dans l'incident et banal alors on a
pris la décision avec mon collègue
Manolo dartui de de nous rendre avec nos
deux guides ou azéristiques donc on a
passé plusieurs barrages on est arrivé
au port du oasis Stan et là la la route
nous a été carrément barré 10 km de
mirancha donc vous pensez que c'est là
où il se cache écoutez c'est là où sa
présence nous a été signalé par
plusieurs sources
discuter avec un colonel des services
secrets pakistanais avec des islamistes
avec des responsables de de
d'école coranique et dans plusieurs
régions du Pakistan toutes les
informations corroborées toutes les
informations recoupées que
la présence de samaba Ben Laden pouvait
plus ou moins être disons on pouvait le
dire avec une quasi certitude au
azéristiques et à Miranda plus
précisément
de charge parce que donc bon à ce
moment-là vous êtes obligé de rebrousser
chemin quand vous arrivez à 10 km de
Mirande chasse vous êtes obligé
d'aller plus loin alors bon on est
rentré mon enquête sur place c'est
terminé au mois d'août on est rentré
donc quelques jours plus tard et trois
semaines trois semaines après la fin de
notre
présence au Pakistan il y a un fait qui
qui m'a conforté dans mes conv une
opération qui qui a eu lieu à l'endroit
même où on nous avait une opération des
Américains des Pakistanais qui ont tué
une dizaine de membres d'Al-Qaïda ça
c'est un premier fait le deuxième fait
le 11 septembre 2003 souvenez-vous ça ma
belle Laden rendu public une cassette ou
on le voit dans la montagne à côté de
imen zahouiri le numéro 2 de
l'organisation terroriste et là
c'est pas que je sois un expert en
topographie ou en quoi que ce soit mais
les les l'endroit
me rappeler un petit peu ce que j'avais
vu au azéristiques et donc j'ai appelé
des sources
pakistanaises qui m'ont confirmé que
c'était bien ou azéristiques alors sur
ce point les autorités pakistanaises
sont restés muettes jusqu'au mois de
décembre où ils ont avoué eux-mêmes que
la cassette qui a été rendue publique le
11 septembre 2000 2003 a été bel et bien
tourné au azéri en fait ce que vous
dites vous
qu'il est oasiristan bien au chaud en
attendant les élections américaines moi
je dis qu'il a été encerclé encerclé
aujourd'hui comment je peux le dire j'ai
travaillé sur la base d'une carte
géographique sur la base d'information
avérées à présent de force spéciale
américaine et pakistanaise donc des
villages dans des régions bien précises
à la fois côté afghan et côté
pakistanais sur la base de cette carte
géographique j'ai tracé en fait
j'ai coché je m'aperçois qu'il y a en
fait un cercle une chose qui ressent où
ça va Ben Laden et pour moi aujourd'hui
encerclé depuis près d'une année et donc
tous ces tous ces gestes sont contrôlés
il ne peut pas bouger énormément et je
vais vous dire une chose ça je vais le
dire ici parce que je l'ai pas dit
ailleurs mais je vais le dire ici il y a
ça fait un mois à peu près j'ai été
contacté à ma grande surprise par
quelqu'un qui qui est dans l'équipe de
campagne de John Kerry et il m'a fait
savoir que John Kerry ou du moins son
entourage avait les mêmes qu'ils étaient
en train de contacter tous ceux qui
avaient enquêté sur cette affaire à
travers le monde pour recueillir le
maximum d'informations et le révéler
cette affaire à l'opinion publique
américaine parce que ça serait très
grave si moi je ne dis pas que c'est
vrai à 100 % mais j'ai je dis que j'ai
beaucoup de doute j'ai beaucoup de
doutes et des doutes qui sont confirmés
confortés de jeux jour après jour donc
si John Kerry s'intéresse à cette
histoire c'est que c'est sérieux si
c'est sérieux il faut que ça sorte et si
ici et si ça sort il faut de toute
manière pour diverses raisons pas pour
ça mais honnêtement il faut que George
Bush ne soit pas réussi je ne suis pas
américain qui vous inquiète en fait
pour le bien de cette planète il y a et
je le dis à la fin de mon livre il y a
Oussama Ben Laden ça serait bien qu'il
disparaisse il y a George Bush ça serait
bien qu'il soit pas réunion
aussi il faut pas qu'il soit qu'il soit
réélu c'est à dire que on est face à des
gens qui sont en train de jouer avec
l'avenir de la planète
donc il appartient dans les démocraties
comme c'est le cas aux États-Unis à
chaque électeur américain de prendre la
décision en son ami conscience que vous
dites en fait c'est qu'il faut pas
laisser à Georges boost la possibilité
d'être élu en sortant de son chapeau au
dernier moment à 15 jours des élections
déjà Laden ouais
c'est moqué de la planète entière ils
sont en train de se passer moi
l'expression se [ __ ] de notre gueule à
tous d'une part mais d'autre part
idéologiquement c'est lui et son équipe
ce sont des gens dangereux il véhiculent
une idéologie fasciste je suis désolé ce
sont des intégristes alors je ne peux
pas en tant que musulman dénoncé les
musulmans intégristes et laisser de côté
les intégristes juifs ou chrétiens je
suis désolé il faut aujourd'hui il y a
une montée des extrémismes partout il y
a un retour acharné vers la religion il
appartient à tout le monde de dénoncer
ses fascistes c'est une autre forme de
fascisme il faut les dénoncer ces
gens-là tous comme ils sont je mettrai
pas naturellement sur le le pied
d'égalité George Bush et où ça m'a
baladen parce que ce sont deux fascistes
différents mais toute proportion gardée
il reste que ce sont quand même de
fascistes
si vous êtes d'accord avec cette idée
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
plausible cette idée que que finalement
les Américains sauraient ou est où ça
m'avait Laden et qu'il le garde en
réserve pour les élections en fait moi
je pense qu'effectivement ils doivent
savoir dans quelle région se trouve Ben
Laden mais entre savoir où il est et
aller le chercher il y a un grand pas et
en plus les américains ils sont pas bons
sur ce genre de terrain là d'ailleurs
quand il y a eu l'opération menée la
dernière fois soi-disant il y avait le
numéro 2 d'Al-Qaïda ils sont cassés les
dents ils l'ont pas attrapé ils ont
attrapé dit malheureux islamistes
terroristes et l'autre il s'est tiré ils
savent pas c'est comme en Afrique ou en
Somalie
pour ça les américains ils arrivent avec
la grosse artillerie bombarde tout le
monde ils expose tous c'est fini donc là
je pense qu'effectivement ils savent
dans quelle région se trouve Ben Laden
ils peuvent pas aller le chercher ils
pensaient ça vous pensez que oisirs au
Vietnam mais comme ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en Irak ils sont
complètement débordés vous pensez qu'ils
peuvent pas aller le chercher osiristan
je pense que ça m'a baladen si les
arrêté d'abord ça sera une opération des
spécial de il y aura un complicité à
l'intérieur même des hommes tribales
donc je pense qu'ils seront assez malins
pour composer avec les deux éléments
c'est à dire une une complicité à
l'intérieur même des intribales qui va
leur faciliter l'accès une opération des
forces spéciales ceci étant vous dites
que la neutralisation de sa Mabel Laden
n'amènera évidemment pas et
malheureusement pas la fin du terrorisme
vous dites que c'est une idéologie
fasciste criminelle raciste xénophobe
antisémite à combattre comme l'idéologie
nazie et Tac je pense qu'il appartient
aux musulmans d'abord et au nom musulman
ensuite parce que c'est le combat de
tout le monde d'éviter ces pièges dans
lesquels on essaye de nous faire tomber
tous c'est cette notion de guerre de
civilisation de garde religion
il n'existe pas de guerre de religion ce
qu'il existe aujourd'hui c'est une
guerre parce qu'elle est là il faut la
voir eux le savent c'est-à-dire les
islamistes savent qu'il y a une guerre
nous en l'ignore
il faut aujourd'hui qu'on sache que ce
n'est pas une guerre qui oppose des
musulmans à des normes musulmans mais à
des fascistes
des fascistes à des gens qui rejettent
et qui condamne le fascisme
entre l'islamisme et les musulmans il
est sur c'est surtout le problème c'est
qu'on entend peu de de voix comme la
vôtre Mohammed Sifaoui c'est vrai que
souvent les musulmans en interviennent
pas dans le débat public pour marquer
leurs différences vous savez je suis pas
je suis pas vraiment d'accord parce
qu'en fait c'est pas ça si je suis là
aujourd'hui c'est parce que vous m'avez
invité donc il y a beaucoup de musulmans
qui dénoncent ce fascisme mais qui ne
sont invités nulle part on leur donne
pas la parole donc naturellement
connaissant la puissance des médias si
on ne donne pas la parole aux musulmans
naturellement personne ne le saura moi
je vais vous dire une chose si vous
permettez je suis et je vais si vous me
le permettez
sur l'occasion de ma présence ici pour
dire que je veux lancer un appel à tous
les musulmans de France pour organiser
une marche pour dénoncer l'islamisme et
le terrorisme mais je dis bien
l'islamisme les touristes c'est une
c'est une c'est un appel qui est lancé
en musulman mais aussi à tous les
musulmans qui adhère à ce combat et qui
adhère à l'idée que effectivement la
guerre en Irak a été une erreur qui
alimente le terrorisme que ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui au Proche-Orient est
une gravissime erreur qui alimente le
terrorisme islamiste tous ceux qui
adhèrent à ses idées et ben je les
invite à m'écrire à Marianne parce que
Marianne le journal Marianne et
Jean-François Ken que vous receviez la
semaine dernière ici même et d'accord et
parti prenante dans cette dans cette
dans cette initiative et donc je suis en
train de préparer d'essayer de contacter
des associations de musulmans et de non
musulmans pour que justement la voix des
musulmans soit visible et qu'on voit en
France que beaucoup de musulmans
dénoncent ce fascisme qui est islamisme
et qui tente et qu'ils feront tout pour
se démarquer de cette idéologie et donc
nous avons déjà d'ailleurs dans cette
dans cette veine
avec avec des amis décider d'organiser
une rencontre internationale au mois de
novembre contre ce que j'appelle pour
Nuremberg contre le fascisme islamiste
et nous 300 signatures dans les 300
signatures un tiers les trois dans les
300 premiers signataires signataires un
tiers sont musulman donc si vous dire
que c'est vrai que nous sommes
quelques-uns à être visibles dans cette
dénonciation de du terrorisme et de
l'intégrisme mais c'est pas parce que
nous sommes quelques-uns advisible que
nous sommes uniquement quelques-uns sont
beaucoup plus nombreux que ça
oui sur les traces de Ben Laden vous
avez pas peur pour vous non non j'ai
peur pour tout le monde parce que le
terrorisme ne vise pas moi il vise tout
le monde aveuglement est-ce que le fait
de se taire me met forcément à l'abri
d'un acte terroriste ce qui était dans
les trains de Madrid n'avait pas écrit
de livres pour dénoncer le terrorisme
mais malheureusement
donc
je ne pense pas qu'il faille penser en
ces termes moi je ne réfléchis pas à
tout ça pour moi et je le dis et je le
répète et n'arriveront jamais en
théoriser c'est plus fort que moi mais
ils n'arrivons jamais à terroriser parce
que d'abord il frappe lâchement et ce ne
sont pas des lâches qui vont me faire
peur et d'autre part ils sont dans une
dans un dans un monde parallèle ils sont
dans une espèce de paranoïa collective
qui qui les emmène vers vers des actes
extrêmement graves et moi je les dénonce
c'est aussi simple que ça vous êtes
protégé quand même oui je suis protégé
mais vous savez je suis croyant aussi je
je suis croyant et je pense que
la mort de chacun de d'entre nous et
écrite quelque part et quand ça doit
arriver ça arrivera par une maladie par
un accident de voiture par un arrêt
cardiaque par une balle par une bombe
par que sais-je donc est-ce que le fait
de se taire me donnerait beaucoup plus
le disons beaucoup plus de fierté fierté
non je peux me regarder dans une glace
et je me sens totalement libre parce que
s'autocensurer et disons éviter de
parler par peur c'est en quelque sorte
faire une concession pour sa liberté moi
ma liberté j'y tiens donc je suis un
homme libre je veux rester en homme
libre je dis ce que je pense et non
déplaise celui qui n'est pas content
c'est la même chose et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de inarritube abonnez-vous
et mettez un pouce bleu